bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau webinaire cette semaine
nous allons reprendre à la suite de la
semaine dernière et continue et du coup
à la session sur la trajectoire de soins
alors j'espère que vous avez pu regarder
du coup la session précédente si vous
n'avez pas vu du coup le milinaire
numéro 17
je vous invite vraiment a d'abord
regardé la vidéo du luminaire 17 puisque
ce soir on va continuer sur une
trajectoire de soins et on va comme je
voulais dire prendre là où nous nous
étions arrêtés la semaine dernière je
vous propose est passé en mode partage
d'écran et donc pour reprendre sur là où
nous étions arrêtés la semaine dernière
je vous fais un petit résumé nous avions
il déjà une première introduction rapide
aux rapports r marc daoud qui sont des
versions plus avancé et plus évoluée des
documents que ce que nous avions fait
avec les la fonction compas louis pauthe
et donc ils nous permettent de générer
des documents au format html world ou
bien un pdf donc là on est vraiment sur
des usages de base de ces rapports mais
c'est sa période sur une première
introduction nous avions vu du coup le
jeu ne donnait donc les données que nous
utilisons en ce moment ce sont des
trajectoires de soins nous suivons des
personnes qui ont bénéficié de campagnes
de dépistage majoritairement à domicile
et à partir du moment où ces personnes
sont diagnostiquées
nous les suivons mois après mois et nous
avons leur statut dans les soins je vous
rappelle un statut ces diagnostics et
n'est pas encore en soins en soins mais
n'ayant pas initier un traitement sous
traitement mais n'ayant pas encore
contrôler leur infection et enfin en
soins sous traitement et avec une
infection control est alors pour
redémarrer aujourd'hui j'ai réouvert la
session la semaine dernière mon projet
studio la semaine dernière vous voyez
ici on sait indiqué en haut à droite
le projet dans lequel je me situe on
retrouve nos différents fichiers qui
après relecture is
qui était le jeu de données à qu'on a
utilisé la semaine dernière et que nous
avons apportées nous avions fait un
fichier trajectoire 0,1 point rmd et
vous avez enfin la version html de
documents qui trajectoire 0,1 point
achetable ce que je vais faire pour ce
soir je vais à partir de mon fichier vc
rouen rmd voyez hein quand je les revers
les prévisions des analystes du moment
sont encore d'ailleurs disponible
d'horaires studio je vais revenir au
début de mon document est ce que je vais
faire ben je vais faire ficher
enregistrer sous c'est à sedan file ces
vases ce qui va me permettre de faire
une version v 0 2 comme ça je vais
garder la version de semaine dernière je
vais repartir sur celle ci je vais
changer la date
aujourd'hui nous sommes le 25 est ce que
j'aimerais du coup sir exécuter tout ce
qu'on a fait la semaine dernière pour me
remettre dans le même état que la
semaine dernière pour ça pour exécuter
en fait l'ensemble du code qui lie à
l'intérieur de mon document et remarques
d'haroun je peux tout simplement aller
dans le menu session et là j'ai une
option qui s'appelle louis stade r and
chips
alors cette option elle est importante
parce qu'elle qu'est ce que permet la
lgv à permettre de redémarrer au démarre
d'une version vierge et dorée exécuté
l'ensemble du code
c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'intéressant lorsqu'on est en situation
aussi de débogage pour retrouver
lorsqu'il s'était mal passé au pouvoir à
quel endroit on va rencontrer je clique
là dessus ça redémarre du coup ma
session r ça va du coup il ya plus aucun
paquet de charges en mémoire et puisse
avoir exécuté tout depuis le début nous
comme je vous le disais l'importance
d'avoir en permanence ou tout début de
son code
la première étape qui est de charger les
package est donné vous voyez la petite
barre verte à gauche à qui m'indique
l'avancé alors attendez j'ai un soucis
parfois ça peut arriver
votre session erquy crash
donc la ra crash et donc c'est pas grave
et on va faire session beast un terre
plein axe
ça peut arriver parfois quand je vous
disais vous avez à la fois l'indicateur
à gauche qui vous dit l'avancé et puis
vous avez aussi d'indicateurs vérifiant
bas qui me dit l'avancé d'exécution de
l'ensemble du code
là on n'a pas encore de grosses grosses
analyse mais parfois ça peut être
beaucoup plus long si on commence à voir
des gros rapports et donc du coup tout
le col est exécuté donc ce que j'ai ici
maintenant mémoire rom et session elle
correspond à l'état que l'on a après la
dernière martin au code et je vous
remontre 1 voici la dernière chose que
nous avions fait la semaine dernière qui
était ce graphique jugé pote 2 qui était
donc un mois par mois
l'état dans les soins donc on voit qu'au
tout début
allen 0 la grande majorité des individus
sont dans l'état diagnostiqués mais pas
suivi il ya malgré tout quelques
individus très peu qui sont suivis mais
pas sous traitement alors ça s'explique
parce que la zone une intervention
d'où viennent ces données il arrivait de
manière très occasionnels que des
individus face le test non pas dans la
communauté mais ils se rendent
directement dans une clinique pour aller
faire un test
et quand les personnes rentrées dans la
clinique on général en cas de résultat
positif on leur faisait le bilan initial
est dans du coup elles sont considérées
comme étant rentré en soins à des ce
moment là et c'est pour ça que nous
avons quelques individus qui sont déjà n
0 suivi mais pas sous traitement sont
peu nombreuses à ceci dit on voit qu'au
bout d'un mois une petite partie est
déjà rentré dans les soins certains même
déjà initié leur traitement et certains
ont même eu un contrôle de l'affection
relativement rapidement même si pour une
majorité de personnes il ya un délai
entre le moment on va être des marins
traitement et le moment où l'affection
va être contrôlé
et donc ce que l'on va faire on va
commencer à regarder en premier lieu on
va tout simplement faire une première
analyse tout survie qui va être une
une manière la manière la plus courante
d'aborder nous donner un biographique
alors l'analyse sur du classique on
l'avait vu le 11 de base
elle permet de regarder le temps que
l'on met entre deux événements
je pourrais regarder par exemple le
temps entre le diagnostic et l'entrée en
soins ou le taux entre le diagnostic et
l'initiation du traitement
donc en fait ce qu'on va regarder ce
sont donc des événements et dans le cas
présent nous avons trois événements
principaux l'entrée en soins qui est le
passage ce statut des diagnostics qui
n'est pas suivie au statut c'est qui est
suivie mais pas sous traitement des
initiations l'initiation d'un traitement
qui est donc l'événement qui a lieu
lorsque l'on passe du statut suivi et
pas sous traitement au statut sous
traitement mais infection control et
connaît donc le passage de ces athées ou
enfin l'événement contrôle de
l'infection qui est le passage du statut
était sous traitement de l'infection
d'un contrôle et au statut s sous
traitement et infection control et alors
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'en tout
rigole il faudrait également considérer
les transitions inverse les sorties de
soins l'arrêt du traitement les shaks
virologique pour le moment on va ne pas
regarder les transitions inverse et
enfin ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que
dans une analyse de survie classique on
peut voir qu'une seule transition donc
un individu qui a diagnostiqué qui va
rentrer dans les soins qu'il va sortir
des soins pour re rentrer dans les soins
ce qu'on va regarder pour le moment
c'est uniquement la première entrée dans
les soins donc
l'analyse survie classique elle est
intéressante mais elle nous limite sur
le fait qu' elle ne sait pas gérer on
verra plus tard un des extensions qui
permettent de le faire gérer les
multiples événements ou de gérer pour
gérer les transitions inverse donc pour
moment ce que l'on va regarder c'est le
ton requis jusqu'à la première entrée en
soins la première initiation du
traitement et la première atteinte du
contrôle de l'affection pour tout ça on
va avoir besoin de calculer la date
d'occurrence de ces événements et donc
du coup l'analyse services se faisant
par l'individu on va avoir besoin d'un
fichier avec unis par individu je vous
rappelle qu'actuellement nous avons un
fichier qui s'appelle claire trajectory
et il contient une ligne par individu et
par mois alors on va faire une nouvelle
partie du coup je me vais faire un titre
vous rappelle que vous avez ici avec cet
onglet le plan documents donc analyse de
sully classique d'accord et donc la
première chose que l'on va avoir besoin
c'est donc d'un fichier individus je
vais créer un fichier inde où jean neveu
du couple souligne par l'individu alors
on aurait plusieurs possibilités
regardez éventuellement aussi on a des
doublons sur la variable individuelle
sur la variable idée qui est notre
identifié individuel là en l'occurrence
je me dis nous avions un fichier qui est
plutôt propres dans le sens où tout le
monde est observé à m 0-1 les gens sont
alors observés plus ou moins longtemps
mais ici on sait qu'ils sont tous
observé anne 0 et donc du coup qu'on a
de 1929 individus on les voit ici / ap 0
donc pour faire un fichier individus je
peux faire assez facilement partir de
quel droit j'actualise et je vais garder
que le mois 0
donc filter qui me permet de faire une
condition et en faisant ça j'ai
maintenant un fichier individus qui
contient 2000 qui contient de 1929
observation c'est assez facile
l'âge un fichier propre comprenons que
le moins 0 j'ai bien tout mais individus
et puis on va regarder différentes dates
alors là les dates 1 elles sont sont pas
sous forme de deux dates calendaire 2012
26 janvier 2012 on est sous des formes
de temps depuis le diagnostic un il ya
un temps qui est exprimé en moins donc
on va calculer c'est la variable membres
qui contient notre informations
temporelles et dans le cas présent nous
sommes dans un cas de figure où tous les
individus ont été diagnostiqués am zéro
puisque c'est le sait c'est le point de
départ en fait du suivi donc je vais
créer une barrière que j'appelle
diagnostic et je lui donne tout
simplement zéro puisque ici pour tous
les individus le temps origines c'est le
temps diront et puis maintenant qu'on a
ça on devra calculer la date de la
première entrée en soins puis la date
la première initiation du traitement et
la date de la du premier contrôle
virologiques
alors comment savoir quel est à la date
d'entrée en soins si je prends mon
fichier qui a injecté au rize d'accord
les gens alors je leur montre un ici à
quoi ressemble la variable d'un variable
statut qui a ce quelque chose qui est
celle qui nous intéresse c'est une
variable textuel qui contient du coup
quelle valeur des cts avec les cas
statut dont on a parlé diagnostiqués
mais pas suivi suivi mais pas ce
traitement sous traitement mais
infections de contrôle et sous
traitement des infections contrôler
les individus sont dans les soins à
partir du moment où ils sont les statuts
cts donc si je prends quelques
projecteurs is et que je fais 1 filter
qu'est stiltz pourcentage in pourcentage
cds alors je vous rappelle pourcentage
in % c'est pour vérifier si une valeur
et dans une liste de valeur donc là on
va garder toutes les lignes où la
variable clé statut secondes s'étaient
où s j'ai donc du coup toutes les lignes
où les individus sont en soins là ce que
je vais faire ensuite je vais calculé
voilà moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est une
valeur par un individu dont j'ai fait un
good bye est la variable individus ses
idées et je vais faire un sunrise
puisque je veux obtenir une seule valeur
et finalement la date de d'entrée en
soit vers la premier mois où les
individus sont en soins de c'est facile
c'est la plus petite valeur de la
variable mois maintenant que j'ai trié
mon statut sur cts donc je vais tout
simplement faire avec mon sunrise et je
vais dire que entrée en soins et yann
minh manche donc je reprends la logique
je prends toutes les toutes les lignes
individus moi je ne garde que les lignes
les individus sont dans les tasses été
ou est ce donc c'est forcément à les
lignes où les individus sont en soins je
fais un groupe by idées pour qu'elles
faire un calcul individu par individu et
je choisis le minimum de la variable
moi ce qui me donnera bien et que
j'appelle entrée soins et ce minimum là
me donnera bien la plus petite des
malheurs donc là le premier mois où
l'individu est considéré comme étant en
soi si je prends ce code là et que je le
mets dans la console
j'obtiens un tableau avec deux variables
la variabilité et la variable entre et
soins qui correspond ce qui m'intéresse
maintenant que j'ai ça je vais pouvoir
récupérer l'information dans mon fichier
inde tout simplement avec un left john
donc inde
ça va être le fichier inde autre je vais
faire un left joël je fusionne ce que je
viens de calcul est d'accord et je
fusionne pas la variable idée réelle
sécu ton toussaint si je prends
maintenant mon fichier inde
mon fichier 1 il contient bien ma
nouvelle variable entrée en soit ce qui
est à retenir c'est qu'il ya des
individus pour lesquels j'ai une valeur
l art manquantes et c'est normal ce sont
les individus qui ne sont jamais rentrés
en soins si un individu n'est jamais
rentré en soins il n'y a aucune ligne ou
le statut vos ct ou est-ce donc il n'est
pas dans ce sous fichier qui est à toi
j'ai je tiens ici
et donc quand je fusionne avec me lève
tôt john hayes on love john je garde
toutes les lignes de gauche à dire de
fring de lundi lui et j'obtiens du coup
ne valeurs manquantes pour les individus
qui ne sont pas entrés en soit autrement
dit la variable entrée en soins contient
deux informations
si elle est manquante cela veut dire que
la personne n'est pas rentré en soins
s'il est documenté ça veut dire que les
personnels d'entrée en soins et dans ce
cas là sa valeur correspond aux premiers
à sao mois de sa première entrée en
soins et donc on peut faire très
facilement la même chose pour calculer
l'initiation d'un traitement
je vais reprendre ce qu au delà et
j'applique la même logique c'est juste
que pour l'initiation du traitement je
ne garde que les status tps
j'ai appelé ça l'initiation et enfin on
va faire la même chose pour le contrôle
virologique qui n'ait atteint peu si
jamais on est dans le statut s
je vais appeler ma variable du coup
contrôle alors ici jeckert state
pourcentage in pourcentage c'est entre
parenthèses est sa vie reste que kate
moss est dans la liste qui ne contient
que s on pourrait écrire sa manière un
peu plus simple uniquement avec un égal
égal c'est équivalent si maintenant
j'aurai exécute tout mon agent qui va
recréer le fichier individus donc j'ai
pas de souci de fait d'appliquer deux
fois un rêve de djak puisque j'ai recréé
individus ici je vous rappelle la fesci
ci permet de re exécuté ce dunk
j'aurais pu faire contrôler à l'excès il
nous manque également une autre
information qui est la durée maximum de
suivi parce que tous les individus ne
sont pas observés pendant la même durée
d'accord et donc du coup j'ai besoin de
savoir où se situe la censure à droite
et ça en fait on peut le faire est la
même manière j'ai juste besoin de savoir
où en fait simplement qu'elle est le
mois maximum je voulais dit le fichier
propre
il n'y a pas trop dans suivi donc si je
regarde simplement le mois max par
individu chez sa durée de suivi
on va refaire un left j'en ai toujours
la même logique
cette fois ci je parle qu'à la
trajectoire vise pour la durée de suivi
je dis bien toutes les données dont j'ai
pas de filter group buy idée sunrise
donc ma variable de suivi
fois ci c'est le max de banff et ça je
fusionne toujours à l'idée sympa suivi
également basculer les mois maintenant
si je regarde mon fichier inde
j'ai bien du coup mes nouvelles
variables à la fin
diagnostic entrée en soi une initiation
traitement contrôle suivi alors petite
précision
ici je n'ai pas mis de nrm égale flou
dans les mines et dans mes max 1
puisqu'il n'y a pas de mots quand sur la
variable mois dans le fichier qui a
purgé autorise ce qu'on peut voir si
j'ai utilisé par exemple questionnaire
ferait qu elle a dû fichier clé 3g
stories je n'ai pas de manquer le mois
ils systématiquement enseigner
quand vous avez des fichiers qui sont
pas forcément propre ou du coup certains
mois serait pas enseigner vous pourriez
avoir des nanas qui serait lié à ça donc
soit vous êtes budget dans votre filter
soit il faut penser à rajouter des l1
pour les rênes quelque part dans le code
en fonction ce que vous faites alors
maintenant que j'ai mis différentes
dates jelal pas de diagnostic
j'ai la date d'initiation du traitement
d'entrée en soins date initiation de
traitement date à 2
contrôle virologique gema durée de suivi
et doit pouvoir faire différentes
courbes de caplong d'ailleurs entre deux
dates
alors comme on va en faire pas mal les
groupes de quatre d'ailleurs j'aimerais
bien en faire une petite fonction pour
ça on va refaire déjà un cas particulier
déjà on va voir par exemple qu'est-ce
qui se passe
donc là on va déjà ça c'était la
construction n'ont fléchi individus
alors je veux mettre en fait quand je
mets un nom ici dans le choc
d'accord c'est un peu comme un
commentaire ça n'apparaîtra pas dans le
rapport final par contre ça me permet de
savoir à quoi correspond du coup mon
jeune qui est de pouvoir plus facilement
me retrouver si je veux quelque chose
qui apparaît sans rapport final qui sont
vraiment visible jeudi les coûts du
texte ou du titre là par exemple je vais
dire on va faire un premier exemple
d'accord et pour ce premier exemple ce
qu'on va regarder c'est le temps entre
l'entrée en soins et l'initiation d'un
traitement
alors petite précision quand on fait des
documents plus tôt ou word ou pdf les
titres on commence par des types de
niveau 1 puis après on met des petits de
niveau 2 puis après on met des tickets
niveau 3 lorsque l'on fait des documents
achetés mêmes qui sont plutôt vers une
page web
ce qui se passait qui a pas de titre
global et documents et donc du coup en
général les types de niveau 1 sont
réservés pour le titre de la page et
donc du coup on va commencer notre
document avec des titres de niveau 2 si
vous regardez ici à première description
puis d'audience pour dire que c'est un
titre de niveau 2 donc là je vais faire
un titre de niveau 3 pour indiquer qu'il
est sous la partie analyse sur bignan et
donc du coup simplement pour faire un
titre de niveau iii j'utilise troisième
donc ça juste petit rappel sur le mark
down
les titres 1 le nom de dièse indique le
niveau titre un pièce pour un niveau 1 3
lié essenti de niveau 3 5 pièces pour un
titre de niveau 5 etc
alors on va vouloir faire une adresse de
survie donc il va nous falloir le
package survival et si vous vous
souvenez pour faire une analyse de cas
quand ailleurs on va pouvoir faire les
quakers avec surf fit de ce maillot il
nous faut deux variables pour construire
d'autres objets événements ils nous
foutent variable ça remue et variables
event la variole events est une variable
de type oui nos souffrances par exemple
ou 0 1 pour vous rappelle l'objet
service secret avec la fonction soeur et
quand j'ouvre l'aide de la fonction sa
valeur dans le cas le plus simple à dire
uniquement sur un droite
il nous faut juste ça rime et events il
ya des cas de figures plus compliqué
lorsqu'on veut être sûre des objets plus
complet avec un temps de début un temps
de faim donc ça ça ne concerne pas pour
le moment donc il nous faut ça râle donc
fournisseur des états qui notre calme
c'est fille six fours le tchad c'est à
dire le temps pour ceux qui ont vécu
l'événement le temps entre le point
d'origine et le moment où on vit
l'événement d'accord et pour ceux qui
n'ont pas vécu l'événement c'est le
temps de suivi la durée maximum par
défaut type
vous voyez il ya plusieurs manières
définir un objet soeur avec bright
lights in servane craintes initiales
qand states nous on est dans le cas de
figure de base on pourrait donc touchera
pas et enfin une faune de variables
events qui permet de savoir si la
l'individu a connu l'événement
dans le cas classique soit c'est une
variable 010 live web jet à 0 n'a pas
vécu l'événement 1 a vécu l'événement ou
cheval
ou inde et dans ce cas là c'est un a
vécu l'événement 1 n'a pas vécu
l'événement de a vécu l'événement donc
on va avoir l'occasion
comment est ce que je crée un objet pour
pour faire ça alors déjà si je veux
regarder le temps entre l'entrée en
soins et l'initiation d'un [ __ ] d'un
traitement
je ne peux le faire que chez les
personnes qui sont entrées en soins
notre date d'origine c'est la date
d'entrée en soins et donc du coup
j'avais un besoin de ne garder que les
individus qui sont rentrés en soins ce
comté diagnostiquer et qui ne sont
jamais rentrés en soi ne vont pas
pouvoir entrer dans l'analyse
je vais faire un tableau tant de colère
que je vais appeler tmp et qui va être
uniquement les individus pour lesquels
qui sont rentrés en soins je voulais dit
c'est facile c'est ceux pour lesquels on
a une date d'entrée en soins donc je
vais prendre tmp fello star is points et
n'a hélas variés à l'entrée en soins
pour l'appeler point de départ c'est un
des revenus et donc la variable d'entrée
en soins
on l'a appelée ont très souvent tout
simplement donc là cette étape là mon
objet tmp ne contient plus que 1200 90
personnes ce sont les 1990 personnes qui
sont entrées en sont maintenant j'ai
besoin de calculer la variable dont elle
a parlé de l'événement alors une manière
simple de voir les choses c'est d'abord
de se dire qu'est ce qui se passe pour
ce jeu considéré que les gens donc pas
vécu l'événement d'accord donc je vais
commencer par le cas de figure je mets
rares événements à forbes n'a pas connu
l'événement et pour les gens qui n'ont
pas connu l'événement la durée c'est
donc la durée de suivi par rapport à
notre origine de l'analyse ici notre
point d'entrée de l'analyse c'est
l'entrée en soins donc il faut que je
regarde naturel suivent
au total - le temps origines de
l'analyse qui s'y est entré en soins je
rappelle tmp suivi c'est la durée depuis
le diagnostic
ici on s'intéresse analyse à ce qui se
passe depuis l'entrée en soins donc la
durée de suivi depuis l'entrée en soins
c'est la durée totale de suivi - la
durée qu'il a fallu entre le diagnostic
et l'entrée en soi maintenant je vais
m'intéresser aux cas de figure qui sont
les individus qui ont qui ont connu
l'événement donc les gens qui ont connu
l'événement c'est à dire les gens qui
ont ici un traitement ce sont ceux qui y
ont une date d'initiation donc ceux qui
ont une date d'initiation d'un
traitement c'est ceux pour lesquels ce
n'est pas mon camp d'accord si je
reprends mp initiation traitement c'est
la date c'est moment d'initiation du
traitement d'accord si j'écris hysen à
de tmp initiation traitement ça m'a dit
est ce que la barrière l'initiation
traitement est manquante l'on vous fasse
donc ceux pour qui ces manques en ont
pas vécu l'événement donc ça et ceux
pour qui ce n'est pas manquants ont vécu
l'événement qu'en fait ils regardent
hispania de temp et initiation de
traitement va me donner l'information
que je cherche mais inversés ça me donne
un jour quand je voudrai du fal c1 farce
quand ça vaut du choo pour inverser une
valeur logique
je vais simplement mettre un point
d'exclamation début qui est l'opérateur
logique non autrement dit point
d'exclamation hysen à de tmp initiation
traitement vous tous si la variable
initiation traitement n'est pas en
compte et vos faces
s'il n'est pas n'est pas mon compte et
en fait c'est la variable événement qui
m'intéresse donc en fait je vais écrire
ma part y avait vainement comme étant
point d'exclamation yz atp initiation
traitement maintenant ce que j'aimerais
c'est modifier la variable time pour
ceux qui ont vécu l'événement
parce que pour cela il faut pas regarder
le temps entre le suivi l'entrée en
soins mais le temps entre l'initiation
du traitement et l'entrée en soi et du
cours au lieu de vous faire en dix plats
hier vers faire un petit peu de de
syntaxe classique 1 2 r donc je veux
modifié tmp times uniquement pour ceux
tels que tmp event et caoutchouc ça va
jusque là donc je prends tel pays times
tels que tnt caoutchouc alors je
pourrais écrire et garou je peux m'en
passer
ce que je passais une condition logique
dans mes crochets alors là je vous
renvoie ou toute première vidéo de de
webinars d'accord donc là je choisis
uniquement la variable taipei times dans
le cas où une tmp event est vrai et dans
ces cas là qu'est ce que je veux je veux
du coup avoir tmp alors initiation
traitement - tmp deux entrées en soi
mais attention il ya un petit souci
c'est temp et initiation traitement ça
me donne toute la variable initiation
traitement pour toutes les lignes
alors là je veux jouer que sûr c'est que
je veux que les lignes c'est vrai donc
en fait il faut que je pense à rajouter
ma condition
ici
ça veut dire tmp time pour lesquels
haven est vrai ça vaut temp initiation
traitement point qu'elle tmp veine est
vrai - tmp en train en soins pour
laquelle tmp dans l'art even est vrai
comme j'ai mis la même condition dans
mes crochets à chacune de ces étapes
j'ai bien le même nombre de ligne ça ça
a le même nombre de lignes que ça et
ceci encore les donc du coup j'ai
quelque chose qui va être correct ça va
jusque là si j'exécute ceci j'ai
maintenant d'objecter mp1 qui m'ont
appelé temporaire qu'il n'ya donc 1290
ligne et si je fais un petit fréquelin
de mon objectif et voyez je n'ai pas de
manquant pour la variable event ni deux
banques ont pour la variable a time
alors si j'ai du times manquant quelque
part 1290 quelque chose que j'ai dû j'ai
dû faire un petit souci alors on va
reprendre tmp un an c'est bien
uniquement mai 1990 individus jeu pour
le moment jamais maîtres de la farce et
je m'étais pétanque en même temps tmp
suivi - tmp entrée soins à cette attaque
la tmb times voilà pourquoi j'ai dû y en
a partout
tmp suivi bien documenté un regardez
j'ai fait une erreur
ici j'ai filtré sur les lignes telles
que entrée soins et manquant alors moi
ce que je veux c'est céline pour
lesquelles ce n'est pas avant quand j'ai
oublié une condition
à cette étape là si je reprends mon
étape maintenant tmp times est bien
documenté et non je ne devrait plus
avoir de manquons ça rime n'a pas de mon
conte ni event vous voyez donc à un
moment donné toujours pensé à vérifier
au fur et à mesure votre code et vous
résultats parce qu'on avait très vite
fait même lorsqu'on est très habitués
offert un petit oubli ou kit erreur
quelque part
donc c'est important de vérifier qu'on a
bien résultat qui est cohérent
maintenant on a ça je vais faire ma
courbe de caplong mayer et la courbe de
tiapoum ailleurs on l'a vu ça se fait
tout simplement avec la fonction search
fit donc mon club c'est tout simplement
se remet vite ce monde oberthur vie ses
soeurs zain evans la cour des capelans
manière de base c'est simplement tilde
one on à pas variable explicative et
j'indique d'attin le tmb
si je fais ça j'ai ma courbe de
capelongue je peux faire un graphique
rapide avec klotz kaplan je vous
rappelle ainsi on veut faire des
graphiques plus poussées il faut charger
gg surv la ggt seul mineur un rebond qui
permet de charger gg sauf pelote je lis
pas ce manque un plan donc là la courbe
2 caps l'ont d'ailleurs fait tangible 2
vous allez voir on va les faire un petit
peu différente mais nous pour la suite
en revanche ce convoi vouloir c'est
plutôt récupérer les données de la
courbe de capoue mayer et donc je sais
pas si vous souvenez
et de la fonction tahiti du package boom
alors le package ou bochum
il a une fonction taiji qui permet de
prendre permettre d'objets de renvoyer
un tableau détaillé est propre au format
en fait tu as dit taillée comme taille
d'hiver sont faites pour facilement
parents de faire des graphiques derrière
on peut l'appliquer à un objet soeur fit
d'accord et dans ces cas là si je fais
ta il dit 2-4 clan d'une précisé que je
veux les intervalles de confiance
j'obtiens un tableau équivalent à
vouvoyer pourquet les 48 premiers mois
donc pour chaque pas de tanger le nomme
individus à risque non événement le
nombre de censure
l'estimation la corne de caplan maya
maroc ce qu'on voyait et les intervalles
de confiance aux ébats en fait on a dit
riton les données qui servent à faire le
graphique de survie et c'est pour ça
qu'à ce stade là je vais le garder
vous voyez là nous avons vu les étapes
ont pour réaliser notre analyse sur
villans n'en a fait qu'une et si je veux
faire un graphique de ça je vais vous
montrer comment le jeu appelé saez mon
résultat et je fais un graphique rapide
donc j'ai fait rejet des pelotes 13 la
courbe de caplan myers et de m
finalement le temps knicks en grec
les estimations si je fais géant live
on obtient bien une autre groupe de
caplong manière de manière très simple à
ce stade la rd fera une version plus
jolie donc vous voyez ça ce sont les
étapes qui sont requises pour prendre
mes données à partir de nos dates rende
mes données faire un fichier temporaire
créé la variable events i'm fair la
courbe de survie et récupérer le
résultat sauf que qu'on va vouloir
garder c'est le ton banquier entre le
diagnostic il entrait en soins entre le
diagnostic et la mise sous traitement
entre le diagnostic et le contrôle
virologiques
mais on voit aussi vouloir garder du
coup le temps requis entre diagnostic
entrée en soit entre entrée en soins et
initiation du traitement qu'on vient de
le faire et entre l'initiation de
traitement et contrôle biologique donc
on va t'on pas comment un joueur trop
faire ça plusieurs fois pourra répéter
je vais créer ma propre fonction et donc
ce qu'on va aborder sait comment créer
sa propre fonction en fait
création fonctions sous verre est
relativement facile d'intérêt c'est
quand on crée une fonction va ensuite
pouvoir la réutiliser à tous à plusieurs
niveaux donc là ce que je vais faire
j'écris donc son j'applique m pour la
cre et je donne son nom j'utilise la
flèche d'assignation et j'appelle
function entre parenthèses puis entre
accolade l'idée c'est que entre
parenthèses on va indiquer les
paramètres de la fonction et entre
accolade
on va et indiquez le code de la fonction
donc là ce que je vais avoir besoin pour
ma fonction c'est pour faire un cap
lomagnols entre deux dates donc date
origines et date de fin d'un montage de
l'événement donc je vais reprendre le
code que j'avais l'air puis qu'on va
reprendre pour créer notre fonction tout
ça faut juste que je décale grand je
sélectionne mes lignes je clique sur
tabulation et voyez ça me laisse
déplacent tous alors l'idée c'est que je
vais donner je vais partir du principe
que j'appellerais ma fonction je
donnerai le texte le nom de la variable
qui contient des origines et le nom de
la variole qui contient date événement
ici je pars du principe annoncer une
fonction personnel donc je ne vais pas
tous passer en paramètres de la fonction
et donc je peux appeler le fichier inde
notable de données inde
ça marchera parce que c'est une fonction
personnel et que inde existe dans
l'environnement et du coup s'il ne
trouve pas un d parmi les paramètres de
la fonction il va regarder ce qui existe
un nom
un qui existe globalement je chercherai
la sphère de fonction plus
spécifiquement dans un package quelque
chose de plus générique
j'aurais dû mettre en fait un paramètre
pour y passer mon tableau de données non
déjà ce qu'on voit c'est que j'ai besoin
de faire un fichier inde tels que la
variable qui est stocké dans des
origines ne soit pas bon compte
du coup j'avais pas pour mais par contre
je peux pas utiliser
voyez cette écriture lac a une écriture
à la deep la guerre parce que si je fais
un supposons que donc date origine soit
égal aux textes contrer soins puisque
c'est ce que on va passer à la fonction
c'est le nom de la fonction si je fais
ceci c'est parce qu'ils se fassent ce
qu'ils regardent enfin si je m'étais ici
date origines du marché lundi pléiade
devenu plus ou plus par an normalement
quand on met notre à badens il m'a
retenu toutes les deux 1929
d'accord ce qui l'a retenu c'est que
date origines vaut un texte qui n'est
pas manquant donc ça revient à écrire
filtre flou il filtered chaud ça retient
toutes les lignes et là j'en ai du coup
de 1929
donc je veux ce que je veux ce n'est pas
le texte date origines mais c'est avoir
accès en fait à la au vecteur date
origine et pour ça il faut revenir à une
écriture classique 1
en général vous souvenez que quand on
veut écrire ans ainsi gérer crise ça si
je vais écrire
l'accès est une variable entre un
classique j'utilise le dollar les
dollars je dois mettre ce qui écrit
derrière c'est le nom la variable or -
bail ne s'appelle pas
d'origine mais date origines contient le
nom de marianne est en fait il faut
revenir à la syntaxe plus fondamentale
qui est celle des double crochet on a vu
au tout début d'accord c'est une p
entrée soins ça correspond en fait à tmp
double crochet entre guillemets entrée
soins d'un double crochet je lui passe
un texte qui correspond non une variable
est bien ce que je peux faire c'est
plutôt que lui passer un texte
directement écrit à la main dans le code
je peux lui passer une variable qui
contient un texte
or là nous avons date origines qui
contient la valeur textuel entrée soins
et si je fais tmp entre crochets date
origine
j'obtiens bien ces deux variables la non
double crochet ça prend un objet textuel
ici l'objet date au régime qui contient
un an de variables et ça a extrait la
variable qui porte ce nom là donc ici je
vais remplacer
c'est mon fils tu as he is points et n'a
de tmp date origines et tous les
endroits où j'ai été mp entrée soins je
mets du coup les remplacer par des
origines
et du coup c'est la même chose pour la
date événement un endroit où j'étais mp
initiation traitement en fait il faut
que je m'étais lp entre double crochet
date événement est à ce stade là j'ai
pas besoin beaucoup plus event et si
elles sont créées je peux garder cette
syntaxe donc en fait le fait d'avoir
écrit des choses plutôt avec une syntaxe
traditionnels c'est ici que ça me permet
de faire mon équipe ou pour facilement
créer ma variable ce qui est important
c'est que je veux récupérer le résultat
d'accords et pour récupérer le résultat
le résultat une fonction c'est le
dernier objet que renvoie la fonction
donc il faut que je disais à la toute
fin de me renvoyer rêve alors
l'exécutons ceci si je fais klm entre et
soins à initiation était donc en fait
voyez je prends ma fonction je suis pas
de nom de variables j'obtiens le tableau
du cap lomagne en question qu'elle
concerne les 639 et à 650 points
si je fais quand même je suis pas savoir
contrôler j'obtiens un nouveau cap le
mayeur qui part aussi avec 1639 par
lui-même point d'entrée mais le nombre
d'événements on voit n'est pas le même
entre 1,0 et mala j'en avais 653 l'enjeu
n'est plus que de 126 donc j'ai une
petite fonction qui tout simplement me
renvoie le tableau du clan mayer et j'ai
juste à lui donner deux variables en
entrée pour le faire rapide et on va
voir du coup pour faire des graphiques
on va le revoir en faire plusieurs on va
fusionner tout ça ensemble
alors du coup pour la fusion ça serait
intéressant de pouvoir stocker un nom
adam données au fur et à mesure ça va
nous aider par la suite
donc j'ai rajouté une option à la
fonction quand même un nouveau paramètre
que j'appelle mon nom je vais donner une
valeur par défaut donc je dire non égale
guillemets guillemets c'est à dire le
texte vide donc ça veut dire que là j'ai
donné une valeur par défaut à l'argument
non donc si je ne fournis pas ça prendra
part d'efforts mais sinon pour elle
précisé est ce que je vais faire c'est
que le juste dire qu'il y aura une
nouvelle variable dans le mon retour mon
résultat
j'ai appelé nom et qui va contenir ce
nom là et donc j'ai maintenant un objet
une petite fonction qui va me permettre
de faire les choses à de gagner du temps
pour la suite
alors ici je reviens à la question de
jamioulx de ça je n'ai pas trop compris
pourquoi c'était nécessaire de la
syntaxe en air classiques
le problème quand vous écrivez des
fonctions voilà là l'information de la
ce que je fais variés c'est un nom de
variables d'accord donc ce que je veux
sélectionné c'est dans le tableau tmp la
colonne dont le nom est stocké dans date
originale
ce que je veux c'est pas la colonne qui
s'appelle date origines je veux la
colonne qui a pour nom le texte qui est
stocké dans tâte origine parce qu'en
fait la difficulté quand on écrit les
fonctions c'est de passer à ce niveau un
peu plus
un peu plus compliqué de l'abstraction
et donc je ne peux pas utiliser une
syntaxe dutil tmp date origine si je si
j'écris tmp date origines j'obtiens rien
parce qu'il n'ya pas de colonne qui
s'appelle d'origine - ce que ce qu'il
faut retenir c'est que date origines
contient la formation entré soins ce que
je veux c'est la colonne la variable qui
s'appelle entrée soins et cette
information entrée soins est stocké dans
l'objet date origine
s'il écrit tmp double crochet date
origine ça veut dire je prends le
contenu date origines qui contient la
valeur textuel entrée soins que je passe
au double crochet pour extraire de et du
coup ce que je vais obtenir c'est la
variable entre et soin d'eux tmp est
créé à ses propres fonctions c'est
toujours quelque chose un peu compliqué
là on est vraiment aujourd'hui bien sûr
des choses un peu plus
c'est ce qu'il faut retenir c est créer
des fonctions propres écrire du code et
des fonctions avec 10 avec le tailles
diverses
c'est plus compliqué parce que la 105e
diverses et une syntaxe qui est avant
tout une syntaxe pour fast et les usages
au quotidien quand on réalise les choses
mais tout événement aux comptes axa
c'est pour ça qu'on programmation j'en
reviens aux basiques de m
parce que j'ai fait un geste les mages
ou en profite pour montrer une fonction
si vous savez pas à les faire c'est
patrick pour ce qu'on va faire ensuite
vous pouvez reprendre ce col de la
classique et c'est juste que les le
recopier six ou sept fois pour à chaque
fois utilisé remplacer les noms de
barrières parce qu'on va faire retenez
simplement que l'on retrouvait programmé
un et que vous voulez que vous avez
l'information du nom d'une variable
dans un autre objet ici j'ai un objet
date origines qui contient le nom d'une
colonne pour accéder à la colonne il
faut passer par un salad des deux
groupes la syntaxe est double crochet
maintenant qu'on en est là donc là qu'on
arrive sur un deuxième exemple donc ce
qu'on fait maintenant je reviens à la
veille de survie maintenant ce que nous
allons faire simple c'est le on va
regarder le temps depuis le diagnostic
maintenant que j'ai fait maintenant que
j'ai ma petite fonction qui va lui
permettre de gagner du temps à l'étape
suivante on va regarder la survenue de
chacun des événements depuis le même
temps au régime
ça lui c'est à dire depuis le diagnostic
donc déjà je vais créer un objet que
j'appelle depuis diag d'accord et je
vais appeler plusieurs caps l'ont
d'ailleurs je veux les fusionner
ensemble on l'a vu pour fusionner en
dépit des tableaux ensemble c'est à dire
ajouter des lignes c'est la fonction par
amy rose qui est conseillé depuis plié
depuis
dipl ailleurs d'accord dont je vais à ma
fonction quand même et je vais faire un
diagnostic
donc je veux le temps du diagnostic à
l'entrée en soins et je vais en profiter
pour appeler ça du coup entraînant soins
je voulais dire le troisième paramètre
c'est un petit nom qu'on rajoute aux
lignes du tableau qui est renvoyé par
qui la fonction quand même ensuite
j'avais regardé le temps entre le
diagnostic et l'initiation de traitement
donc c'est la variable initiation et et
je vais pour sas et initiation
l'initiation et enfin entre le
diagnostic
et le contrôle de l'affection qui est la
variable propre rôle alors si j'exécute
ceux ci qu'est ce que j'obtiens dont
j'ai appelé trois fois la fonction qu'à
m d'accord donc je vais récupérer trois
tableaux de résultats qui sont fusionnés
ensemble et donc un objet depuis yagg
regardez à quoi il ressemble il a les
trois tableaux de résultats les uns
au-dessus des autres donc on a la
variable times qui nous indique le temps
d'accord estimate qui contient le niveau
de la courbe de survie alors c'est le
nombre de survivants a pas ce qu'ont
vécu l'événement mais on peut calculer
facilement ce qu'ont vécu l'événement
oui enfin vous avez voilà la colonne non
un objet rajouter tout à l'heure me
permet du coup de bien distinguer mais
trois résultats et j'ai compris qu'on
flou mais interroge de confiance aux
ébats et bah du coup à faire un petit
graphique de tout ça donc je vais faire
un café dont jean clottes
je vais prendre du coup depuis yagg
et on va déjà représentés du coup en x
le temps et en y
alors je suis pas trop intéressé de voir
le nombre de gens qui donnent tout leur
avait vécu l'événement j'ai plutôt
représenté ce qu'ils ont vécu
l'événement
donc c'est un mois estimé
je les séparer du coup mes trois groupes
donc je vais utiliser la couleur color
et gaz non plus j'ai un bail pour faire
du coureur
donc la premier rendu graphique 1
j'ai mes trois graphiques entrée en
soins
l'initiation du traitement et contrôle
de l'infection
alors si vous regardez j'ai bien les
informations ce qui est un petit peu
bizarre c'est que dans ma légende
l'ombre et pas forcément
hélas le nom ici c'est je ne suis pas
dans l'ordre de ce que j'ai fait puisque
j'ai contrôle entre initiation donc ce
que je vais faire en fait c'est quand je
vais créer mon objet depuis yagg
je vais juste dire que je veux que non
ça soit fct in order dans un facteur qui
est dans le land de mon tableau si j'ai
fait ça j'ai bien les états dans le bon
ordre
entrée en soins et l'initiation du
traitement contre l'infection alors
ensuite ce qu'on va rajouter c'est les
intervalles de confiance et pour ça on
va le faire car oui bonne mais qui va
avoir besoin de quelques esthétique
supplémentaires il va falloir un tic y
mines et un y max dont classe si je
reviens à mon objet depuis diag d'accord
j'ai comme point à y est content point
l'eau qui sont des intervalles de
confiance aux ébats alors comme l'âge et
j'ai fait mon un mois estimé il faut
aussi j'aurais applique sommes donc y
minzah 1 - compte pour un accueil y max
égal 1 - confie le haut
et puis je vais remplir aussi couleurs
et je vais faire fils et il ya le nom et
je vais rajouter alors
j'aime moins bonne juste en dessous
alors là on voit pas forcément grand
chose parce que mon ruban il est en
couleurs pleines et donc on a intérêt a
indiqué enfin parler de transparence a
jamais tu reprends 25 et donc du coup
mais rubans sont maintenant rempli de
manière transparente ce qui se passe
c'est que j'aimerais bien que le voyez
paramètres color a aussi un impact sur
les bords du ruban et je voudrais
désactiver du coup pour les 13 je veux
pour leur humour je vais pas dessinée de
13 ans aurait en bas je veux juste
garder le ruban en transparence et jeu
que montrait principal au milieu et donc
du coup je vais changer le mapping
comparé à mettre ma ping dans une
géométrie me permet de modifier
l'association et citic valeur et je vais
indiqué phil color égal non en faisant
ça voyez j'ai supprimé les très hauts et
bas qu'ils avaient sur mon graphique on
va un tout petit peu allégés graphique
donc je vais rajouter un petit m la x
quelque chose qui a un petit peu plus
léger on va déplacer les gens là les
gens d'en bas donc thème legends pour un
position ils gagnent bottom à quelque
chose
un petit peu plus lisible si je prends
le thème classique peut-être might alors
il y en a quelque chose qui est encore
légèrement légèrement plus plus léger
avec ce thème classique j'ai fait juste
rajouter des lignes horizontales
donc je vais faire le la grille du panel
donc c'est pas les gros hits
je veux que on y est que pour les lignes
principales donc ça va être panel points
gullit midjo y est donc ça c'est sondés
l'hymne donc et lemon klein color dégâts
ou vraie saveur et je veux rajouter
s'est mis ses lignes là pour faciliter
la lecture
et puis on a encore quelques petits
éléments par exemple mon axe dx je vais
peut-être pas aller jusqu'à 50 ans
fument précédemment s'arrêtait à 36 mois
je vais faire pareil
donc on va prendre ce qui est x continue
hausse
je vais changer les limites du graphique
donc limite légale
c'est 0.36 donc là je vais limiter à 36
noirot graphique et puis je faire des
breaks ce que tous les six mois
donc vous l'ex égale à 6 x 6 36 02
points 6 x 6 l'âge indiquent des
coupures à 0,6 mois 12 mois 18 mois qui
sont plus faciles à dire puisqu'on est
du coup les mois où quand ça arrange
en ayant deux mille années et puis pour
faciliter encore on va afficher des
vrais pourcentage sur l'accès y est on y
continue
donc pour celles qui font la fonction
personne tu du package skins
si je veux pas changer ce qui est juste
pour ça je peux appeler la fonction avec
la forme non du package de points deux
points dont la fonction donc là ça
permet d'aller chercher la fonction père
cents du package clients ce qui va
transformer les 0.25 ans 25% et
maintenant on va à mettre à jour
peut-être une partie des étiquettes ce1
donc x lab l'étiquette on x et moi
depuis le diagnostic
je vais aller j'ai l'étiquette verticale
et puis je les supprimer les étiquettes
de la légende donc color et quel vide et
nous avons donc maintenant un graphique
plus léger alors ici ça ce graphique
ressemble un petit peu la casquette de
soins qu'on avait vu au tout début
à quelques différences près ici est
habitable de kaplan meier l'ascension à
droite
donc le fait que tous les individus
n'ont pas la même durée de suivi est
correctement prise en compte et à coups
mais bien corrigé en conséquence la cour
d'ici va tenir compte du fait que
certains individus sont suivis plus ou
moins longtemps
par contre ma vue on voit que la
première transition ici nous avons pas
pris en compte les trois y sont le vert
lorsqu'un individu atteint un état on
regarde pas si leur sort
une autre manière ceci dit de regarder
tout ça annoncée de c'est à voir dans
quelle mesure n'ont pas le temps depuis
un même point origines c'est à dire
depuis le diagnostic lui de regarder
plutôt le temps depuis l'étape
précédente
là on a vu moi ce que
on a ici comme état ce sont des étapes
ah bon à qui s'enchaînent les unes aux
autres donc on peut le regarder une fois
que je suis entré en sourit il faut
combien temps pour initier le traitement
pour ça on va reprendre notre code
précédent parce que vu qu'on a tous fait
sous la forme on optimisait un autre
clou on va pouvoir le faire de manière
plus facile donc là au lieu de gagner
depuis l'étape précédente c'est dingue
hein en fait depuis liane 6 depuis
l'étape précédente donc je vais faire un
nouvel objet et on commence toujours
avec du temps entre le diagnostic et
l'entrée en soins mais ensuite on va
regarder le temps de le montrer en soins
à l'initiation du traitement puis étant
de l'initiation du traitement au
contrôle de l'infection
donc là on va essayer c'est vraiment
rapide de réadapter puisqu'on a déjà
beaucoup mutualiser et pour le graphique
donc je vais reprendre mon code d'avant
j'ai juste changé depuis presse alors
faut juste que je change peut-être c'est
moi depuis l'étape précédente
et donc on a tout de suite le nouveau
graphique
donc là cette étape ce que l'on voit
c'est le ton requis depuis l'étape
précédente
ceci étant dit le présenter comme ça et
pas forcément ce qu'il ya de plus
intuitif
ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est là en
rouge vous avez depuis line au stick le
temps qu'il faut et à quelle vitesse les
gens vous rentrez en sont
puis une fois qu'ils rentrent en soins
on a le temps d'initiation du traitement
l'envoyer beaucoup unis si le traitement
très vite d'aller deux tiers qui nie
sinon quelques mois et après c'est un
petit peu plus long et puis enfin on a
le temps de contrôler de l'infection et
voyez au moins de six mois la plupart
des gens depuis qu'ils ont si les
traitements athéniens contrôle et à une
infection
mais comme on est sur des stades qui se
font les unes après les autres
représentent les tout les ans au dessus
des autres pourrait être légèrement
trompeur il donc c'est peut-être le plus
intéressant de rajouter ici une facette
pour faire des graphiques côte à côte
si je fais face est paysan rose égale
vase non j'ai faire trois colonnes
plutôt donc j'ai utilisé comme ce et
donc j'utilise et non pour faire mon
graphique ça reprend le même graphique
mais là j'ai mis trois graphiques côte à
côte ils ont bien le même le même axe
''six on voit bien que là on a le plus
de perdition
c'est l'entrée en soit on sait l'on
rentré en seconde ça m'a pas mal de
temps mais ensuite ça va beaucoup plus
vite sur l'initiation traitement une
fois que les gens soient en seconde ils
sont compris l'affection c'est un petit
peu plus long mais on arrive à des
niveaux cloud et voyez là en plus on
garde cette idée que je mets un certain
temps pour entrer en soins puis je passe
à l'initiation traitement puis au
contrôle de l'infection
donc là on est on a quelque chose qui
est plus qu il est plus intéressant
bien entendu une fois qu'on a fait ça on
pourrait avoir une étape suivante de
l'analyse qui est passé à la maison
10 variées alors en faisant du coup des
capelans d'ailleurs en regardant les
mêmes graphique par âge et par sexe
faire des modèles de cox éventuellement
pour ses différentes étapes donc et
regardent et les facteurs qui sont
associés c'est une des possibilités donc
elle ici face à un phénomène un peu
complexe on peut voyez vous en plus
différents caps ont d'ailleurs un peu
simple et on pourrait tout à fait se
dire qu'on va on refait le même
graphique ici mais cette fois ci en
ajoutant à la dimension la dimension à
part sexe on va le regarder
soyons fous regardons ça donc si je vous
ai regardées selon sexe donc là ce que
je vais faire
j'ai accompli de fonction et je m'en
faire une offre que j'applique am sexe
et c'est juste que ça s'appelle bien sec
soit variable officier dont fichiers
individu ça ça l est se x d'accord donc
ce que je vais faire je vais prendre la
voir la cam sexe ce que je vais faire je
vais créer une variable tmp sexe avec un
peu en français qui va être la version
tout factor
jusque là vous voyez que le sexe est
codé en 1/2 hommes-femmes donc tout
factor de tmp
c'est que tout coup et ensuite j'ai
demandé à faire une analyse en fonction
de sexe
je vais les reprend du coup depuis
presque en fonction du sexe
j'ai appelé ça depuis presse sexe
j'aurai besoin du coup la fonction quand
même sexe ainsi que j'exécute où ça on
va voir ce qu'on obtient donc j'ai une
variable depuis presse sexe dont le
voyez j'ai bien un tableau ce qui se
passe c'est qu'on a du coup une strata
en plus un cantona c'est juste par
contre c'est sous la forme sexe de pont
légal homme ou sexe égale femmes
mais du coup vous avez strata 1 qui
contient une information on peut être
qu'on va rajouter si je vais faire une
variable depuis presse sexe de fernie la
javel sexe et qui du coup c'est ma
stratégie je veux retirer les depuis
prés sexe de la strate à atteindre
vérifiez la variable sera ta c'est un
facteur humain textuel donc c'est un
texte d'accord ce que j'ai fait je vais
le dire et les 1 2 3 4 5 premiers
caractères ce qui normalement se faire
esther seube pour prendre un tout une
première partie et je vais indiquer
start et il ya six pour dire je veux
garder à partir du sixième caractère si
je fais ça est ce que j'obtiens bien ça
c'était de lantier variable sexe
continuellement aux hommes et femmes
donc maintenant on va aller refaire
notre graphique donc le code graphique
précédent c'était celui ci donc je vais
reprendre un graphique sauf que je
prends maintenant depuis presse sexe et
que par contre la couleur ça la pâte en
fonction du nom cette en fonction de
mots variable sexe que je vais utiliser
la couleur puisque j'ai en face a
écrites sur le nom est donc là si vous
regardez j'ai maintenant donc la même
analyse qu'est ce qu'on voit c'est que
en termes d'entrées en soins il ya une
vraie différence visible entre les
hommes et les femmes
vous voyez que les internes lui
confiance ne se chevauchent pas du tout
les femmes ont rentré beaucoup plus
rapidement en soins que les hommes les
hommes mais beaucoup plus de temps pour
rentrer en soins on voit ensuite et
administration du traitement les deux
courbes sont très proches 1 les
intervalles de confiance se superposent
en partie là on n'a pas fait le test
proprement dignement peut supposer qu'en
termes de paix valeur il n'y a pas
vraiment de différence et donc du coup à
cette initiation de traitement il ya
plus de différences dans la prise en
charge des hommes et des femmes et enfin
si on regarde le contrôle de l'infection
donc c'est me tendre pour faire partir
randonner de l'initiation de traitement
les individus à retenir contre lui
l'affection il est l'un encore une fois
peu près similaire peut-être un petit
peu en dessous par pour les hommes alors
peut-être qu'il faudrait aller vérifier
avec un bon break un test avec un test
statistique s'est pas dit quelles
différences soient vraiment
significatives
ça pourrait être soit que les femmes
biologiquement à une réponse à un petit
peu plus rapide au traitement soit
peut-être une différence en terme de
bonne observance au traitement que les
femmes prendrait
mieux leur traitement que les hommes et
donc du coût atteindrait un petit peu
plus vite le contrôle de l'infection
après initiation du traitement et voyez
c'est quand même relativement élevé dans
les deux cas vous voyez en tout cas
comment même si là on n'a pas tous prêts
ou quand on n'a pas l'air trop les
sorties de soins on a une première série
d' analyse de survie simplement en
multipliant plusieurs années de caplan
bailleur ou plusieurs modèles de coques
ce soit les différentes étapes on peut
déjà commencer à faire analyse un petit
peu plus poussé je vous propose que l'on
s'arrête là pour ce soir plutôt que de
se lancer à sur un tour type de dalle is
la semaine prochaine alors je sais pas
encore quelle soir ce sera encore
probablement de bouger s'est joint est
vraiment la part de l'année où tout doit
se récupère et donc du coup les conflits
d'agenda sont particulièrement nombreux
mais la semaine prochaine du coup on va
continuer le même jeune données et cette
fois ci on va reprendre ces derniers là
pour faire une analyse séquence sur
l'ensemble du fichier
on va voir la séquence elle elle va
pouvoir permettre de tenir compte de la
succession des détails du temps passé
dans chacun des états et donc en analyse
de séquences qui sera possible de
ressortir de soin de revenir en arrière
même de ressortir rentrer prendre tout
ça en compte de notre analyse
je pense que l'analyse de séquences
risque de nous couvrir l'ensemble de la
session la semaine prochaine j'ai bien
vu un pour celles et ceux qui ont déjà
répondu la petite enquête des webinaires
que vous préfériez des sessions un peu
plus courte et donc ensuite après
l'analyse séquence on abordera dans une
session encore rude qu'ailleurs
je pense l'avait modèle mixa crises
latentes et les modèles de survie multi
états qui sont une extension des modèles
de survie qui permettent justement de
prendre en compte des ascensions
ascendante et descendante et des états
d'hiver en tout cas
si pour votre écoute pour ce soir on va
continuer du coup sûr ce sur ce jeu
donnait encore quelques sessions je
pense que ça va tenir jusqu'à l'été
et puis très bonne soirée à vous et à
très bientôt
merci